en el vídeo pasado empezamos a platicar
como un banco podría ser la contabilidad
para la reserva fraccionaria verdad
decimos de una manera muy tradicional o
sea de la forma en la cual lo hemos
estado entendiendo todo este tiempo la
idea era que alguien depositaba 100
millones de pesos 90 millones se presta
verdad se le da a alguien que hace
proyectos el pasivo correspondiente es
que la persona a puede venir y pedir sus
100 millones de pesos y de esos 90
millones que se hicieron en préstamos el
activo correspondiente lo que se obtiene
a cambio pues básicamente dijimos que
eran pagarés lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es aclarar que esta es una buena
forma de pensarlo porque es una forma
muy clara pero lo que el banco puede
hacer es un poco distinto en realidad
puede crear el activo puede crear este
activo de acá puede aumentar a ambos
lados de su hoja de balance y pues nada
más puede tener 10 millones de pesos en
reservas ahora una cosa que quiero
aclarar como en todos los vídeos es que
estos no están hechos para justificar el
préstamo de reserva fraccionaria o bien
para descartarlo simplemente es para
mostrarte cómo se puede hacer la
contabilidad y después tú mismo puedes
decidir si te gusta o si no te gusta
vamos a hacer este mismo ejemplo pero
ahora vamos a hacer el ejemplo déjame
empezar de una manera similar como en el
vídeo pasado entonces otra vez yo compro
10 millones de pesos en activo para
tener un banco esencialmente es el
edificio las bóvedas los cajeros las
computadoras y todo eso entonces ahorita
yo si tiene ese dinero entonces otra vez
soy el dueño del banco todo eso lo tengo
en capital tengo 10 millones de pesos en
capital verdad entonces mi capital sería
de 10 millones de pesos voy a ponerle
una flechita y ahora supongamos que
llega una persona y en vez de depositar
100 millones de pesos como en el vídeo
pasado supongamos que la persona y otra
vez viene pero ahora nada más deposita
10 millones de pesos déjamelo como por
aquí tengo un activo verdad que se llama
10 millones de pesos en billetes ok y
acá a la derecha tenemos un pasivo
correspondiente la persona a tiene el
derecho de exigir 10 millones de pesos
no mejor vamos a ponerle la persona ve
la persona ve sólo tiene el 10% del
dinero de a entonces esto de aquí es la
cuenta de cheques de la persona
la cuenta de cheques debe ahora esto de
aquí se va a ver muy anti intuitivo al
principio es un poco anti intuitivo y
oscuro pero como el banco sólo debe de
mantener el 10 por ciento de lo que
tiene en reservas del 10 por ciento de
sus cuentas de cheques como acá en vez
de prestar este dinero entonces el banco
va a mantener las reservas y
automáticamente expandir sus cuentas de
cheques entonces supongamos que voy a
este banco yo yo yo salman khan y quiero
50 millones de pesos quiero un préstamo
entonces dicen ok pues este cuate si me
da confianza para utilizarlo en
proyectos educativos y entonces sí me lo
prestan saben que se los voy a pagar y
entonces lo que pueden hacer es en vez
de darme dinero en vez de darme billetes
en efectivo o sea no lo van a hacer ni
siquiera pueden hacerlo verdad pero lo
que van a hacer es crear una cuenta de
cheques de 50 millones para mí entonces
deja lo pongo por aquí eso de ahí va a
ser un pasivo estoy aquí es la cuenta de
cheques de saldo
ahí está obviamente pues el banco no
está regalando me lo verdad lo que va a
hacer es hacer un activo correspondiente
que básicamente es un pagaré mío lo
escribo voy a ponerle por aquí un
préstamo a sal ese es un activo porque
en el futuro les voy a pagar entonces
vamos a ponerle aquí el préstamo a sal o
más bien un pagaré de ésta le va de sal
ok entonces supongamos que mariana viene
ahorita estamos inventando nombres pero
mariana viene y quiere tomar prestado
otros 40 millones de pesos sale el banco
prensa y piensa que es una buena
inversión déjame aclararlo verdad esto
de aquí era de 50 millones 50 millones
de pesos estoy acá era de 50 millones de
pesos y era un pasivo verdad esto de
aquí puedo escribir cheques por 50
millones
50 millones bajan entonces puede
escribir 50 millones para pagar cosas ya
sabes para comprar una computadora o una
diadema para hablar en la computadora lo
que sea incluso podría pues cobrar esos
cheques pero el banco ahorita no tiene
suficiente dinero el banco ahorita le
preocuparía mucho que yo cobrará esos
cheques en efectivo verdad tendrían que
tomar prestado
central o tal vez de otro banco vaya de
alguna forma pero vamos a seguir
haciendo esto para que veas que podemos
llegar a hojas de balance totalmente
equivalentes entonces decíamos que quien
que mariana verdad llega quiere un
préstamo de 40 millones de pesos y el
banco dice si está bien te lo presto
aquí tengo el activo correspondiente y
el pasivo entonces pues le van a prestar
40 millones como no tienen la reserva
van a crear una cuenta de cheques para
marian entonces aquí está la cuenta de
cheques
mariana de 40 millones claro otra vez no
le van a regalar el dinero aquí ponen un
activo correspondiente verdad entonces
tiene un pagaré de 40 millones de
marianna muy bien ahora puedes decir
sabes que es el banco pues podría seguir
haciendo esto verdad puede inventarse
más y más dinero puede crear más activo
y más pasivo porque estas cuentas de
cheque realmente son dinero verdad esto
de aquí son cheques con los cuales las
personas pueden realizar transacciones
entonces es dinero pero la cosa es que
el banco no puede seguir haciendo esto
infinitamente porque hay un requisito de
reserva el banco sólo puede hacer que la
razón de cuentas de cheques a reservas
sea lo más 10 o bien que las reservas
sean al menos bueno esto depende de país
en país favorita para que las cosas no
salgan así más fácil y estás vamos a
ponerle que sea de 10 por ciento va
entonces si el banco central de cada
país da un requisito para regular las
cosas pero ahorita es de 10% 10% de las
cuentas de cheques
y entonces 10% de las cuentas de cheques
deben dejar como así debe haber reservas
para el 10% de las cuentas de cheques
ok esto es lo que esencialmente detiene
los bancos de hacer esto infinitamente
este banco ya está en su tope ya está
limitado por las reservas que tiene y
pues ya sé que esto se ve un poco oscuro
y un poco anti intuitivo verdad parece
que el banco está creando dinero de la
nada verdad bien si se ve un poquito
sospechoso verdad esencialmente le está
diciendo a las personas sabes que ahora
hay 100 millones que puedes utilizar
para hacer transacciones y sólo hay 10
millones en reservas verdad el resto son
activos son cosas que me van a pagar
pero es exactamente lo que está pasando
aquí a la izquierda verdad aquí también
tenemos 10 millones en reservas y 90
millones en un activo de cosas que nos
van a pagar ok esa es la concepción usa
le llega a alguien deposita 100 millones
de pesos de ahí prestas 90 millones y
sólo tienes 10 millones en reservas
entonces estas dos cosas de acá estas
dos hojas de balance en un sentido
funcional son equivalentes cuando son
completamente equivalente es verdad así
si a la derecha te preocupa que aparezca
dinero nada entonces a la izquierda hay
un problema equivalente y en realidad
tienes un problema con el sistema
bancario de reserva fraccionaria y no
solo con lo que pasa en el lado derecho